c'est pas leur hôtel et bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors le gouvernement
argentin prolonger la période de
négociation de sa dette au 2 juin est ce
que le signe que cesse le signe tout
simplement que le payer ses créanciers
sont proches d'un accord
comme la chienne bois laser alors sur ce
sur ce point-là there a le soutien du
fmi qui depuis le début reconnaît que la
dette est de toute manière impeccable
donc à partir du moment où le soutien du
fmi qui ne sorte de label de qualité que
vous impose des mesures d'austérité
drastiques mais qui là pour rassurer les
créanciers
combien il y a de fortes chances qu'on
arrive à un accord par contre il y a
quand même des points de divergence et
là on est sûr de l'ajustement entre
entre différentes périodes entre
différentes échéances
dansons sous par exemple buenos aires
voudrait suspendre le paiement des
intérêts jusqu'au jusqu'au 15 novembre
2023 et suspendre le paiement du capital
pendant trois ans alors qu'un des
principaux créanciers argentin qui
d'ailleurs mène la danse parmi le groupe
d'équipés les créanciers blackrock
on ne connaît d'ailleurs en france
malheureusement et bien voudrait
suspendre le paiement des intérêts
jusqu'en 2021 seulement et ne donnait 40
grâce pour le capital c'est à dire que
on est on n'est plus vraiment en train
de discuter du montant de la dette
là dessus il ya des restructurations
assez faible finalement mais c'est
surtout par rapport au moment où il
faudra la payer alors on sait que
l'argentine doit également régler le
paiement d'intérêts estimé à 500
millions de dollars on risque de se
retrouver en défaut de paiement quelles
en seraient les conséquences
alors aujourd'hui l'argentine en défaut
partiel en défaut technique dans son
souci 500 millions ne vont pas être payé
aujourd'hui
la date était la date limite est
justement le 22 mai les conséquences ne
sont pas très grave
cette fois ci parce que les créanciers
vont continuer à négocier avec le
gouvernement
et ça ne change pas grand chose qu'on
soit hier ou demain par rapport à ccg à
ses échéances la chanson soul argentine
la capacité d'emprunt l'argentine qui
est nécessaire pour couvrir ce déficit
chronique de devises et bien de toute
manière compromise aujourd'hui plus de
presque plus personne
le prêtre l'argentine hormis le fmi donc
on arrive dans une situation où il n'y a
plus que le fmi qui vous prête
de toute manière vous êtes mal donc ce
défaut partiel ne va pas compromettre
des négociations on sait que le pays est
en récession depuis deux an l'inflation
atteint des sommets la pauvreté aussi
que peut faire aujourd'hui le
gouvernement pour relancer son économie
cette histoire finit mal concrètement le
gouvernement a très peu de marge de
manoeuvre pour relancer son économie
puisque en efface d'ailleurs une crise
totalement inédite à la fois une crise
de l'offre une crise de la demande et
une crise financière qui arrive est
d'ailleurs seraient les trois les ventes
avec la crise de l'économie réelle au
niveau mondial donc un pays comme
l'argentine a tout à perdre puisque s'il
ya une crise au niveau mondial les
exportations de l'argentine va encore
chuter et ça va aggraver ces problèmes
d'accès aux devises non sens aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a plutôt choisi de
protéger sa population face aux
querelles un virus au sens où vous avez
seulement 416 décès en argentine contre
27 mille en france par exemple ou si je
me trompe pas c'est un petit peu moins
de 20 milles au brésil ça se paye avec
des points de croissance en moins la
chute du pib argentin est estimé à
environ 7 % pour 2020 mais ça correspond
plus ou moins la chute du pib de la
région donc finalement le gouvernement a
plutôt a plutôt choisi abolition de
privilégier la santé de sa population
malgré le fait qu'il fallait sacrifier
quelques points de pib mais en
comparaison ce n'est pas si grave par
rapport aux autres pays
mais pour relancer l'économie
l'argentine est en train de mettre en
place des mesures classiques finalement
qui ressemble pas mal aux aides aux
aides qui sont attribués en europe etc
sauf que cette fois ci les différentes
des différents titres qui seront émis
pour financer les nouveaux déficits et
bien sont financés directement par la
banque centrale
ce qui veut dire qu'on s'en moque plus
en dollars ou plus tellement dollars
pour financer pour financier ces
nouvelles dépenses très bien pablo
rotelli économiste spécialiste de
l'amérique latine merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions